TRIP BY ANY STRETCH.
>> JIM, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WANT TO BRING ANUSHAH INTO THE
CONVERSATION AND PLAY SOME VIDEO
OF A STUNNING MOMENT, JIM WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE PUBLICITY OF
THIS, AND HOW MUCH WE'RE SEEING
THAT YOU SEE THAT CHAIN AROUND,
THE GOLD NECKLACE AROUND THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NECK THERE.
SAUDI KING SALMAN PRESENTED THAT
TO THE PRESIDENT, IT'S A GOLD
MEDAL, THE COLOR OF ABDUL AZIZ
AL SAOUD.
IT'S THE NATION'S HIGHEST HONOR.
WHAT IS THE SYMBOLISM THERE?
WHAT IS THE INTENTION AS HE
GIVES HIM THAT HONOR, BECAUSE
ALREADY WHAT WE ARE SEEING, THE
GRANDEUR OF THIS WELCOME IS SO
DIFFERENCE FROM WHAT WE'VE SEEN
WITH PAST PRESIDENTS.
>> I THINK DONALD TRUMP HAS
ALWAYS TAKEN A SOFTER STANCE
WHEN IT'S COME TO SHAB.
THEY WERE LEFT OFF OF HIS FAMOUS
MUSLIM BAN LIST AND ALSO
EXECUTIVE ORDER BARRING MUSLIM
IMMIGRANTS FROM THE U.S. AND
DESPITE SAUDI ARABIA BEING ONE
OF THE GREATEST EXPORTERS OF
ISLAMIC RADICAL ISLAM, DONALD
TRUMP HAS ALWAYS TAKEN A SOFTER
STANCE ON THEM AND LET'S NOT
FORGET THERE'S $109 BILLION ARMS
DEAL ALSO ON THE TABLE THAT HE
HAS TO SEAL WITH THE SAUDIS.
THERE COULDN'T BE A BETTER TIME
FOR DONALD TRUMP TO BE OUT OF
WASHINGTON AND ESCAPE THE
SEEMING-LIKE ATMOSPHERE HE'S
FACING BACK AT HOME AND BE IN
SAUDI ARABIA BUT AT THE SAME
TIME THIS AMBITIOUS TRIP IS FULL
OF DIPLOMATIC LAND MINES.
>> I WANT TO ASK BUT THAT, CAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPEAK WITH
AUTHORITY TO THESE 50 MUSLIM
LEADERS ABOUT THE RELIGION OF
ISLAM AND THE RELATIONS BASED --
IN THE WAKE OF EVERYTHING HE HAS
SAID ABOUT MUSLIMS AS HE WAS A
CANDIDATE PRIOR TO THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> YOU KNOW, FRANKLY, CHRISTI, I
THIS IT'S OFFENSIVE FOR DONALD
TRUMP TO BE PONTIFICATING ON
ISLAM ESPECIALLY IN SAUDI
ARABIA, THE BIRTH PLACE OF ISLAM
AND THE PLACE OF SOME OF ISLAM'S
HOLIEST SITES.
HE SHOULD TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
NOT TO PREACH AND LECTURE BUT
FRANKLY APOLOGIZE AND LISTEN AND
LEARN.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THIS
PRESIDENT RAN HIS ENTIRE
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN ON
ANTI-MUSLIM RHETORIC,
ANTI-MUSLIM SENTIMENT AND I
REALLY DON'T THINK HE'S THE
RIGHT MESSENGER FOR A MESSAGE TO
BRING A MESSAGE OF PEACE AND
UNITY TO THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> ALEX PAPAS, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THAT?
IS HE THE RIGHT PERSON OR DO THE
SAWED EASE CARE SO MUCH ABOUT
WHAT WAS SAID DURING A CAMPAIGN.
CAN THEY WRITE IT OFF SAYING
HE'S JUST SAYING THAT TO GET
ELECTED.
>> THEY BY WHAT HE HAS TO SAY
ABOUT THIS, WHETHER HE'D USE THE
PHRASE RADICAL ISLAM INANHIS
SORT OF SPEECH, A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE THINKING PERHAPS HE'LL TAKE
A MODERATE TONE BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT DOES PLAY TO HIS
AUDIENCE.
JIM ACOSTA MAKES AN INTERESTING
POINT THAT STEVEN MILLER IS ONE
OF THE GUYS WHO IS ONE OF HIS
AIDES HELPING HIM WRITE THE
SPEECH.
HE'S A FORMER AIDE TO JEFF
SESSIONS.
HE'S A TRUE BELIEVER.
IF HE HAS A REALLY STRONG HAND
IN THIS SPEECH, THAT WOULD BE AN
INDICATION TRUMP IS NOT
NECESSARILY GOING TO TAKE THE
MOST MODERATE TONES AND WOULD
STILL SPEAK IN WAYS HE DID
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
>> SO I WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE PLACEMENT, THE SEATING
ARRANGEMENT THAT NIC ROBERTSON
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE KING SALMAN IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS COFFEE CEREMONY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO HIS RIGHT,
THE FIRST LADY, MELANIA TRUMP TO
HIS LEFT.
ANUSHAY, A LOT OF FAMILIES DO
BUSINESS TOGETHER IN SAUDI
ARABIA.
IS THAT A COMMONALITY THAT SAUDI
FAMILIES SEE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHEN WE SEE IN THE
CONTINGENT HE HAS TAKEN THERE,
HIS DAUGHTER, IVANKA, IS WITH
HIM.
HIS SON-IN-LAW, JARED KUSHNER,
ALSO HIS SENIOR ADVISER, IS WILL
W HIM.
IS THERE A COMMONALITY THAT THEY
SHARE THAT SAUDIS ARE FOCUSING
ON?
>> THERE SAY COMMONALITY BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S ONE THAT YOU
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF DEMOCRACY WHEN IT
COMES TO SAUDI ARABIA.
WOMEN ARE STILL FIGHTING FOR THE
RIGHT TO DRIVE, STILL FIGHTING
FOR THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN SAUDI
ARABIA, AND YOU NOTICE IVANKA
TRUMP IS NOT WEARING A HEAD
SCARF, WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT A
LOT OF FOREIGN DIGNITARIES AND
THEIR SPOUSES DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO ABIDE BY BUT IN SAUDI
ARABIA WOMEN ARE LEGALLY
REQUIRED NOT ONLY TO HAVE A MALE
GUARDIAN FOR SIMPLE THINGS A
LOWED TO TRAVEL OR SEEK MEDICAL
ATTENTION BUT THEY ALSO HAVE TO
BE COVERED FROM HEAD TO TOE SO
INTERESTING NOTE NEITHER